today we're going to talk about one of
the best remedies for your lungs and i'm
talking about the lower respiratory
system
whether you have a lung infection or
asthma or even copd
this could be very beneficial for you so
what do you have in common with these
three conditions well you have
inflammation you have an immune reaction
and you have a vasoconstriction where
your lungs are tightening and you can't
get enough air and the common treatment
for lung conditions is
bronchocorticosteroids okay the problem
is when you take it over time you become
resistant so in other words this steroid
works less and less and less now the
problem with myself
not for a lung infection but for poison
ivy is when i took steroids every single
year through my 20s
i noticed it worked less and less and
less to the point where
one year it didn't work at all
so the more you use steroids the more
they don't work
now i want to talk a little bit about
your lungs in relationship to vitamin d
vitamin d is a very
potent
remedy for a lot of things including
inflammation in your lungs however
there's some mixed studies that show
some positive results
some less results
in relationship to asthma and lung
infections but in general vitamin d
is antimicrobial
it helps modulate or regulate your
immune system and also it's a powerful
anti-inflammatory it also supports the
smooth muscle of your lungs so it can
help you breathe better but my question
is why would it work in some people but
not
others okay well
one interesting piece of data you need
to know about is this right here it's
called polymorphism
more and more people are becoming aware
of this condition in relationship to
your vitamin d receptor okay
now you can get a genetic test to
determine if you have a problem with
this but basically to make it really
simple your vitamin d receptors are not
receiving vitamin d like they should so
even though you're taking a certain
amount of vitamin d whether it's 4 000
international units or 6 000
international units
you may not see the benefits from
vitamin d because the receptor is not
receiving vitamin d so that might
explain
why some people might experience
benefits where someone else might not
unless they do this test and find out
they need to greatly up the dosage of
vitamin d
to even 50 000 iu's every single day to
see the results in fact there was one
study and i'm going to put a lot of
studies down below you can look these up
where they use 50 000 international
units of vitamin d every single day for
a few months and they showed
great results with asthma but the point
is if you have a problem with your
vitamin d receptor the normal amounts of
vitamin d are not going to be effective
then there's something else infrared
okay
infrared light therapy has been used for
a lot of things it can actually inhibit
bronchoconstriction and help you breathe
better it's a powerful anti-inflammatory
it can even help decrease fibrosis in
copd
plus infrared can actually decrease
pollution in the air all right and then
we have another thing called
uv light okay ultraviolet light
ultraviolet light can help sterilize or
kill germs they even use uv
in helping purify water or killing
microbes in your water pipes so uv can
help decrease pathogens in the air which
might otherwise overload the immune
system all right so now the big question
is what can you do to combine all of
these things at once to have the perfect
remedy for your lungs well it just so
happens to be
the sun okay the sun gives you uv light
it also gives you uvb radiation that
actually helps you increase vitamin d
naturally and it's very inexpensive it's
actually free the sun also gives you
infrared therapy so that's naturally
built in to the sun which has a direct
effect on the lungs
and inflammation and your immune system
as well as stimulating melatonin okay
now i'm talking about melatonin
in the
mitochondria not the pineal gland which
is a whole different topic i'm talking
about the other benefit of how infrared
can increase melatonin in all of your
cells and so this is something new that
you may have never heard about before
but melatonin has another function other
than helping you sleep at night it has a
powerful antioxidant function in all of
the cells in the mitochondria it has a
lot of benefits one is for the immune
system there's a there's another study
that shows that it can actually help
decrease
coughing okay so
getting more sun can give you all of
these benefits
also one side note vitamin d
helps decrease
corticosteroid resistance so if you've
used steroids in the past and they don't
work vitamin d can help correct and
reverse some of that now here's some
things you need to know about the sun
obviously you don't want to go in the
sun until you burn right
you want to get a certain dose of the
sun the spectrum of the sun
to the point where maybe you get a
little bit of a tan but not overdoing it
now one really interesting thing
when you walk into the woods all right
you'll see a lot of green plants
below the canopy of trees so you'll see
them in the shade growing fine and
you're probably wondering now i thought
it takes the sunlight to make
chlorophyll this green stuff in the
plant well it just so happens that this
wavelength infrared
can penetrate through this canopy of
tree layer and go right down into these
other plants it can also penetrate
through your clothing all right it can
actually penetrate through your skull
about two inches into your brain and it
goes into your body so that being said
you don't always have to get skin
exposure from the sun
just by being out in the sun even if you
have a hat sunglasses and layers
that infrared will penetrate your
clothing and get into your body and
improve your lungs so what am i saying
i'm saying be out in the sun more often
if you have weakness within your lungs
and you also get the extra benefit of
being in fresh air because there's a lot
of pollutants that are indoors that can
also negatively affect your lungs now if
you haven't seen my new video on
melatonin that would be a really
interesting next video for you to watch
i put it right here
you